how are you doing I'm so so well I'd be
even better if I could see your face
just a second how to do this yeah hey
dude virtually of us I thank you for
positivity on Facebook and on social
media it's been great seeing you so
active and absolutely killing it I'm
just literally jumping on calls with
people offering encouragement hearing
stories putting stuff out on social
media and share it share people's
stories said thanks for currently Co but
most poorly thanks for all the
positivity actually we take him well
thank you very much and also I am very
hard to speak with you you are my great
example so thanks very much for calling
me up for that now you sound welcome so
tell us tell us what we should be doing
so interesting interesting because you
know I source property deals right and
when the lockdown came suddenly there to
be some really really good properties
inside of city center in Attleboro right
like flats that you cannot get in normal
circumstances because you know all those
landlords they ran a DMVs themself so
normally is not possible to get them but
basically what happened
these plates are empty now and landlords
are you know they are staying there with
empty properties so okay that's the best
opportunity for me to come in and try to
grab some deals and we honester it's
it's a great help for landlords they are
open to guaranteed real solutions they
are happy for for a fixed term contract
you know two three years rather than get
on a long term tenancy because they know
once they get on a long-term tenant they
will probably lose the whole idea of
running it as a B&B you know yes so I
did lots of contact once taxes
collection I did in the past
I always saved the phone number for the
landlords so anytime I spoke with any
kind of landlord I always save his
number and first thing I did I just text
everyone do you know do you have any
flat in the city center you know so
slowly I started to get deals and I
promoted it very much to anyone I know
to my mailing list to friends to
Facebook groups
never post my deal on the group but I
always say I had something coming that
if you are interested you know getting
that and I found investors who wants to
take on these deals you know and that's
basically what happened so at the moment
I'm working for the investors to provide
them with these deals which is great you
know
excellent so so your strategy is then
you're packaging the vector s ideals and
then you're selling them to investors
exactly and how how our investors found
in that because right now serviced
accommodation is of course had to almost
not halt but it's been massive affected
by the crisis so what's what more
arrangement you arranged with the
language when you what's the agreement
because it seems like a very strange
time to be getting serviced
accommodations in a way but at the same
time there's massive opportunity but I'm
interested how you give it exactly well
a good question you know first of all a
lot from my investors I don't say that I
am the most smart person in the world I
rather learn from those who had
experienced it and the feedback I get
from investors is that yes we are now in
difficult times we might have to three
months you know difficulties with
getting guests yes when the market comes
back Edinboro is a very hot place for
tourism you know wedding bro is very
small and those central locations they
will always work well for Airbnb and
basically for tourists because there is
shortage of hotels and those people will
have to stay somewhere you know yeah and
this is not what I say but that's the
viewpoint of my investors who are buying
those deals yeah this is the situation
I'm not making anything up those words
are empty probably gonna stay empty in
April or we might get response workers
or a long-term booking you know just but
then when all this is over people you
know they will start to travel and you
have a good chance you know it's not
that's reasonable because you're not
advising anyone you're not saying this
is gonna happen in a mobster you saying
look I don't know what I do know is this
is the opportunity to say these are the
figures this is the agreement and I
presented the opportunity I've worked
hard to get this and this is my thing if
you want to pay right no problem
exactly you know what I would suppose
say with every single deal that I send
out to investors I write it clearly
there that this is the high-risk
investment at the moment because we
don't know how the how long the lockdown
will last but look you know it's up to
them if they are willing to risk couple
of thousands with a vision that when
everything turns back to normal we have
fringe festivals coming next year and
the year after
it's canceled this year but it's gonna
be back next year which is imagine
anymore doubles in population during the
Fringe Festival
so people are sleeping out on the street
you know so that's a great opportunity
for investors and also we here at the
Edinburgh crash course a couple months
back oh yes of course
it's me how was the crash course for you
in Edinburgh now you see I have been at
three crash courses first and enjoy last
year in a Birmingham then once again in
Birmingham and now finally in Edinburgh
you you came very well that was amazing
I was so happy for that and you know any
crash course is great because it's not
the boring you know about numbers and so
on but it's full of energy
it's positivity it gives you motivation
you give people motivation to reach you
know a bit higher level than they think
they can you know and that's amazing and
of course not saying that there are
strategies that we can learn so for
example when I came to your crash course
I used to have the small businesses in
the past I had no idea no clue about
properties so all this what I do now
it's still you know it's a little bit a
miracle that actually there is a service
that can help investors and landlords
and someone everyone benefit from it and
I can earn money that way you know so
it's amazing that's really cool
how many tales that if you manage to
package yourself recently so during the
lockdown just you know during the
lockdown I have sold rebuilds and these
are done stalled
the account investors happy clothes
bills I have others which I'm working on
for two investors on misspoke basis and
if everything goes well there will be
two more deals this week but I can't say
because we haven't signed the contracts
I have got the deposits but I haven't
got there you know it's not caused yet
so
to underway and how much you charging on
average per day so basically I charge mm
yeah
but with the two bills I have solved
from these three I say look if someone
takes both of them I give a discount so
it was 750 for each deal at these two
and then the third one was 4 mm
fantastic so so on average you get about
2,000 and you'd your own tractor and
couple this week so on average you kind
of do in a deal a week during lockdown
which is just incredible which is why I
couldn't not just you know great great
for everyone and think much like you
have a conversation because I'm sure
that once everything's back to normal no
doubt you're gonna be a winners
Wednesday on the channel I'm sure
hopefully there's the plan you know is
this I made the decision I say to
everyone I can't become from this it's
only gonna be matter so so basically
I've been a small business owner since
2010 since I left school so I did all
kind of services service companies you
know marketing the printing delivery of
marketing materials I used to have a
cleaning business a commercial cleaning
business so I used to work with clients
and with employees so you know that's
that's a skill that I'm using now
because essentially what I do I don't
really work with properties where I work
with people so every time I'm trying to
package a deal it's mostly about
communication how to handle the investor
and how to handle the landlord you know
and create a win-win situation between
them and I did that in past because you
know when you have employees and clients
you always have complaints and stuff you
have to you know somehow coordinate all
these so yeah that's my background here
antastic
that's right and have you heard about
the crash course going online
I didn't crush those three times I would
highly suggest that you go through
online practicals as well well yeah
that's you know what I tell you
I hope I'm gonna be so busy with deals
just now but you know that's the
luxurious problem so fantastic that's
right listen really really good to have
you on the call if you need anything
from myself for the team drop us a
message on social media and I really
look forward to seeing you sell these
two deals this week as well thank you
very much Tony well god bless all the
best to you and thanks very much for
everything you're doing are you so
welcome my friend thank you all right
bye-bye